all right so every now and then I come
across a bit of filmmaking so baffling
that it just gets stuck in my craw for
days like the editing for Suicide Squad
did that and earlier this week I
rewatched rent for the first time in a
decade and oh boy do I have a thing for
you now to be clear I'm going to be
talking about the craft of filmmaking
the specific art of telling a visual
story so editing blocking and
cinematography rent has many problems
but the movies been out for 12 years and
the musical has been around for 20 so
it's a pretty well trod path to point
out that marine is emotionally abusive
and gaslights her girlfriend Joe and
that Mark is a misery tourist who
refuses to use his relative privilege to
help his marginalized friends that Mark
is an awful artist who exemplifies the
worst habits of lazy artists that Benny
is making fairly sensible decisions but
rightful criticisms of gentrification
are absent in favor of calling him a
sellout that mark quits an incredibly
well-paying part-time job just so we can
finish cutting together his home movie
was just from here on in I shoot without
a script that the story commodifies the
HIV epidemic as window dressing to give
the characters the pathos of a death
sentence rather than say anything cogent
or meaningful about the way the society
reacted to HIV and AIDS in the 80s and
as it marks principal concern for the
homeless stems from his belief in the
transitive artistic properties of
suffering thus living next to homeless
people makes him and his art more
authentic and real by extension
so we're going to acknowledge that all
of those criticisms exist and instead
focus on one specific scene and the
deeply confusing filmmaking choices made
in the framing of that scene okay
context for the uninitiated rent is a
1996 musical set in 1989 slash 1990 New
York against a backdrop of urban decay
in the rampaging HIV crisis in 2005 the
stage musical was adapted for screen
with Chris Columbus yes the home alone
guy directing the story follows an
ensemble of characters most of whom RHI
b-positive through a pivotal year in
their lives in the scene that we're
concerned about me me a 19 year old
stripper and heroin addict played here
by rosario dawson has just gotten off
work and is looking to party so she
heads upstairs to the apartment of Roger
a mid-twenties unemployed musician and
hiv-positive recovering heroin addict
oh also Roger is still recovering from
the death of his girlfriend who killed
herself when she found out she was HIV
positive so he's got a bit of damage
that he's working through Mimi comes in
ready to bone and pulls out her heroin
Roger doesn't take this well tells her
to get out they back-and-forth he kicks
her out and then when we get to the
resolution of the scene and just okay so
in the song that they're singing Mimi is
saying that she's she's super free and
awesome because she lives every day like
it's her last 100% in the present and
like she argues that this is totally
awesome and the best so they should
totally shoot up and bone
oh she's HIV positive too but we as the
audience don't know that yet and the
characters don't know this about each
other and they don't tell each other
until later cuz it's a big it's a big
reveal thing anyway she's arguing the
hedonist perspective embracing
indulgence self-destruction is what
Roger needs to get out of his
existential crisis Rogers side of the
argument is more tempered and well a
little bit more mature you're so wise
then tell me
his point and the title of the song
another day comes from Rogers admonition
that she should prove she actually cares
about his personal demons by coming back
another day and not bringing heroin this
time he's actually really firm with that
one
leave the heroin behind I keep
mentioning the heroin because I don't
want you to forget it it's a pretty
pivotal element to the conversation and
to Rogers whole motivation since you
know he can pretty much a draw a direct
line between his former heroin use and
his dead girlfriend and really almost
everything that's awful about his life
also I don't want you to forget it
because the movie immediately forgets
that these characters are talking about
heroin the set up for the songs finale
is that Roger has kicked Mimi out she's
gone down to the street so immediately
we're setting up symbolic levels roger
is in a position of power a position of
perspective literally the higher ground
while Mimi is literally standing in the
gutter so far we're fine it's a little
blunt but whatever but then here's where
it goes weird everything else about the
blocking the lighting the framing all of
it biases in favor of Mimi Roger is in
shadows and darkness and the bars of the
fence are like a cage it's very students
guide to symbolism meanwhile Mimi is
bathed in angelic light and the rest of
Rogers friends all walk Ian down at
street level and join Mimi and imploring
Roger to give up his perspective and
just live like he's about to die all
four of them repeating the line no day
but today over and over no day but today
no day but today
oh sure roger has a higher ground but
look how sad and lonely and conflicted
he is up there come on Roger climb on
down here to the gutter join your
friends who are totally right and
correct and the ones you audience should
be cheering for empathize with Mimi
Roger is clearly the unreasonable one in
this conversation
oh poor Mimi did mean old Roger not want
to do heroin with you shame on him for
not coping with his trauma on a
timetable that was convenient for you
what's the message here supposed to be
okay so I get that there's this
undercurrent of trying to get Roger to
open up a little bit find some human
contact but the framing of that is still
really important Mimi isn't trying to
coax Roger into going for a walk in the
rain she wants him to shoot heroin and
have sex with her intent isn't the only
thing that matters it's kind of
important how you ask and the thing is
that the visual dimension is so powerful
that it will basically overwhelm any
other consideration the show doesn't
just present a philosophical argument
between living for the day and living
for tomorrow and then leave it to the
audience to sort out if they agree with
me me or Roger the show makes a
judgement the show picks a side and that
side is pretty unambiguously Mimi side
Roger is given the higher ground but
he's also as mentioned already caged by
the fence and framed in relative
darkness or at the very least shadows
lit with a reverse key the chosen angle
is also rather severe this combined with
the facial acting places Roger less in a
position of power and more in a position
of isolation
Mimi however is out in the open the
camera is down at personal level
so while Rogers angle reflects Mimi's
point of view that she would be looking
up at him Mimi's angle doesn't reflect
Rogers this isn't a straightforward
reverse where we're seeing each
character through the other's eyes
instead the camera positions us as the
audience down on the street with Mimi
the camera is our surrogate in the world
of the film and we are placed with Mimi
to finalize this at the end of the song
at the end of the argument we end of the
scene with angel comforting Mimi that is
the consequence that we're shown we get
to see the emotional fallout of this
argument from Mimi's perspective that
she's hurt that she feels rejected and
the angel another sympathetic character
comforts her we are shown this to the
exclusion of seeing the impact on Roger
now we can probably infer that Roger
went back inside and sulked a bit that
this whole thing put a wet towel on his
night but inference is dramatically
inferior to being shown especially when
it comes to building resonance in the
audience building empathy and getting
the audience to invest in the emotional
state of a character story's movies in
particular are ultimately quite morally
simplistic unless they go out of their
way to build nuance and ambiguity into
every aspect of their story
selling they almost always come out in
terms of right and wrong because the
camera introduces so much inherent bias
that it's overwhelming and that's what
happens here the film is telling us that
Mimi is right and Roger is wrong but
again
Mimi isn't just talking about coaxing
Roger out of his shell this isn't just
about his unwillingness to open up to
her emotionally and allow himself to
feel vulnerable it is about those things
that is a part of the message here but
it is more specifically about doing
heroin and having sex with her doctor
Mimi sees his pain and the cure she's
got is sweet sweet drugs and getting his
dick wet so yeah there's that rent I
tell ya
you